[Musique]
l'hymne national ukrainien de retour à
Carson après plus de huit mois
d'occupation russe la population se
réveille d'un cauchemar
pendant tout ce temps les gens avaient
peur c'était effrayant de sortir dehors
les soldats russes étaient partout et
beaucoup de gens ont disparu il y a eu
beaucoup de kidnapping
nous attendions nos soldats comme des
dieux nous sommes si heureux
le président bolo demerselenski s'est
rendu à Carson ce lundi pour la première
fois depuis le début de l'offensive
russe il a été accueilli comme un héros
santé à vous tous comment allez-vous
merci nous avons confiance en vous et en
le futur
mais la place de la Liberté n'est pas
qu'un lieu de célébration c'est aussi
l'unique endroit où la population peut
recharger ses téléphones à l'aide de
générateurs et se connecter à Internet
grâce à une tour téléphonique temporaire
les infrastructures essentielles ont été
en grande partie détruites par l'armée
russe durant les combats il n'y a pas
d'électricité pas d'eau pas de connexion
téléphonique pour les gens qui n'ont que
le chauffage électrique il fait très
froid chez eux
qu'est-ce que ça peut faire le plus
important c'est que personne soit
ukrainienne l'hiver approchant les
autorités publiques doivent travailler
vite notre tâche principale est le
déminage et la rénovation des
infrastructurés essentielles je pense
que l'électricité sera rétablir
rapidement dans notre district et la
ville de Carson
même si tout le monde ne peut pas encore
se chauffer en attendant la population
continue de chanter
[Musique]